-Hey, everyone.
Every week, we like to bring you
some uplifting creative videos
from around the country.
We usually
do this on Wednesdays,
but we're changing
things up this week.
It's time for,
"What Are You Doing Wednesday:
Friday Edition."
-♪ What are you doing?
It's Wednesday ♪
-♪ Or Friday ♪
-♪ What are you doing
on Wednesday? ♪
-♪ I said Friday ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Did you write that
five minutes ago?
-[ High-pitched ] Yeah. I did.
[ Laughter ]
-Insane!
-"Insane!"
First up, this pet owner taught
their dog an amazing new trick.
Check this out.
♪♪
-Piece.
Good.
Up top.
Yes!
Good job.
Okay.
Good.
Up top.
Yes, good job.
-Dude, come on.
That dog plays Jenga
better than I do.
Next, these kids
got into a bit of trouble.
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Luna.
Really?
[ Laughter ]
-I love "Reallys."
"Really?"
"Really."
[ Laughter ]
Can't argue with
that confidence, man.
Here's another one.
This woman had a fun surprise
for her family.
She got them together
for a group photo,
but, well, you watch.
-Ready?
Say cheese.
-Cheese.
-Oh, that didn't come out good.
Hold on.
Say "Mia's pregnant."
-What?!
-No.
No, you're not.
-Don't do that.
-That's mean.
-[ Laughs ]
-I did say it.
-Don't do that.
-What? Are you?
-Really?
-[Bleep]
-Can you please say it?
-Hold on.
Let's take it.
I want to get a picture
of everybody.
-Oh, yeah!
Just -- Are you serious?
-Ready? Say...
-Aaaaah!
-..."It's twins."
-No, it's not.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's [bleep] not.
-It's [bleep] twins?
Are you [bleep] kidding me?
It's twins?
It's [bleep] twins?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Got the photo.
Got the photo.
That's classic right there.
And, finally, I've always wanted
to Roller Blade.
You ever Roller Blade, Tariq?
-Uh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Nope.
-I could see you
rockin' Roller Blades.
-Well, the closest I've come to
Roller-Blading was ice-skating.
-Yeah.
-And, uh...
I'm never gonna do that again.
[ Laughter ]
Nope.
-I think it would be cool, man.
I just don't know how to stop.
I figured it'd look cool,
I'd get the look down.
-Well, yeah.
The look is --
That's half the battle,
but stopping is the other half.
-L.A. Looks.
Yeah.
I'll, like, Roller Blade
to a museum
or something cool like that.
Something like that.
-Yeah.
Headband, fanny pack.
-Yeah, maybe
feather in the headband.
-Yeah, a little feather
in the band.
-Maybe BluBlockers.
-Of course.
Got to get BluBlockers.
-Maybe the headset
that's also an AM/FM radio.
-Dope, yes.
That's it.
-And then,
maybe a snake around my neck.
-Oh, man, that's the look, yeah.
-Anyways, I just don't know
how to stop,
and, well, she doesn't, either.
Watch.
-Help me!
I can't stop! I can't stop!
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
-[ Laughs ]
-"Hey, I'm good!
I'm good!"
There you go, everybody.
That is "What Are You Doing
Wednesday: Friday Edition."